Hi everybody.
Today I will be answering the question,
why do trad wives,
traditional wives,
use the term trad wife instead of housewife homemaker?
Why that term
and what is the difference?
I wanna make a disclaimer.
This is my take on this video.
This is what I have gathered
from other traditional wives as well as myself included.
But there are other traditional wives
who have also done videos like this.
I will tag them in the caption or the comments,
so feel free to go check out their videos.
They are lovely.
Traditional wives here,
online as well.
The media will tell you traditional wives are.
That is false.
And now we're gonna get into this video.
So to preface this,
let's go over what a traditional wife is,
or just a more basic understanding.
A traditional wife is a woman, a wife
who adheres to traditional gender roles in her marriage.
Wife, homemaker,
husband, provider.
So now that you know that,
let's go into some of the more in depth
reasons why we use traditional wife.
I want to add that other women in this circle,
along with myself,
we do interchange the words tradwife,
housewife and homemaker.
There are some differences,
but we've all used these terms.
One of the differences with traditional wives
is our priorities and our values.
Traditional wives are all over the world.
They come from all sorts of different backgrounds,
faiths, ethnicities.
But today I will be talking about Christian
traditional Wives.
Christian traditional wives
believe in biblical submission,
so this is a topic that you will see
often in the traditional wive community.
That is why we talk about submitting to our husbands.
And this does not mean
the wife is of less value than the husband.
But our husbands do have the most authority
in our marriages.
So going back to the difference between housewife,
homemaker, trad wife,
you can have a wife who stays home,
adheres to traditional gender roles,
but she might not believe in submitting to her husband.
But Christian traditional wives do believe in this.
On to the next point.
It is not uncommon for traditional wives
to supplement their husband's income.
The Proverbs 31 woman was very enterprising.
Therefore, it is not uncommon to see traditional wise
sell things online,
such as ebook cookbooks, aprons,
handmade baby clothes,
handmade skincare.
Some traditional wives will watch children, be mothers,
helpers, doulas,
dog walkers.
The keyword here is supplement the husband's income.
And not all traditional wives
need to make a little extra money.
But this is also
what makes being a traditional wife so realistic.
Supplementing your husband's income
is usually just a little extra money.
It's not going to be enough to obviously
live off of,
but it can help.
And it could be the difference between
getting generic produce
or organic produce for your family.
It could be the difference between
putting nicer clothes on your children
and getting your hair done,
or Your nails done,
if that is something that is important to you
and makes you happy.
But our priority is at the home and with our family.
So while we may supplement our husband's income,
it does not come before our home, our family.
That is our number one priority.
The husband's number one priority
is to protect and provide for his family.
The traditional wife's priority is her home, her family.
But of course,
if she wants a secondary source of income,
a little extra spending money,
she can totally do that.
So that is the difference between a
maybe modern housewife
and a traditional housewife.
As a traditional wife
making a little extra money,
it might also be a seasonal thing for you,
because the commitment is not always the same as
maybe a full time job,
if that makes sense.
So when people are
commenting on different traditional lives pages saying,
aren't you making money?
Or this and that,
we aren't offended.
To make money,
it's okay to bless your family.
Our priority is at home and our family.
But there's nothing wrong with a woman
making a little extra money.
And it is very traditional for a wife to do that
if she wants to.
Traditional wives believe in budgeting and frugality.
Our priority is our lifestyle.
So if we have to sacrifice certain materialistic things,
we will do that
because we want to continue living this way.
And if we have to have less things,
In our life
we will do that.
Traditional wives love thrifting.
Our clothes might be second hand,
our homes might be filled with used goodies,
but that is okay
because we love a deal.
Traditional wives love dressing nice
even while at home
because we spend most of our time at home
for some of us.
And we enjoy celebrating
being wives
and putting our best foot forward
every single day.
We know our husbands love coming home
to a put together wife,
so we do enjoy dressing up for our husbands.
So as you can see,
being a traditional wife
is a lot about your values
and your priorities as a wife.